everybody we're back my next guests very
funny comedian please welcome Zach
Galifianakis
[Applause]
hello my name is uh Zach Galifianakis
and uh I hope I'm pronouncing that right
[Music]
I'm named after my granddad my middle
name my name is Zach granddad
Galifianakis
I was a Febreze in my beard today
thinking about what I was going to talk
about and I think I'm just gonna open up
and talk please be quiet I'm very
interesting my brother has a DD which is
weird because he drives a Ford Focus I
told my brother that joke and he didn't
laugh because he got distracted by a
squirrel
[Music]
I went to my high school reunion not too
long ago and that was something I was
home-schooled so it's just me there next
to a bowl of punch listening to Kool &
the Gang talking about how fat I've
gotten
I have gotten fatter which sucks because
I'm claustrophobic at what age do you
tell a highway it was adopted
[Music]
I pick around seven because they start
thinking I don't look like the Kiwanis
Club
[Music]
my agent called me the other day and she
was like Zach you have an audition for
Triscuits commercial and I said is there
any nudity and she said yes
and I said I don't have to make love to
a cracker do I okay that's not true I
just wanted to write a joke where the
punchline was I don't have to make love
to a cracker do I which would be
different if I were a black comedian
[Music]
I would open up a maternity shop and
call it we're screwed I think that sign
in neighborhoods that says slow children
playing is so mean
[Music]
I like to go to the Olive Garden by
myself on Saturday nights and have the
waiter seeing that Happy Birthday song
to me and just sit there and cry my
girlfriend looks a little bit like
Charlize Theron and a lot like Patrick
Ewing
[Music]
the president's dog's name is miss
Beazley I can't believe the president's
dog and my penis have the same name
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]